moi je suis profondément européenne et
parce que je suis profondément
européenne j'estime que l'union
européenne et ses politiques actuelles
qui vise à faire un gigantesque
concurrence entre les peuples et à ne
certainement pas tirer vers le haut les
droits les protections bon ça c'est une
europe qui va dans le mur avec ses
traités néolibéraux et son
fonctionnement qui n'est pas classique
ou dans les ici qui n'est pas très
démocratique donc voilà donc une
mauvaise humeur que nous exprimons au
moment où on voulait le remplacer par
l'onu n'ont pas comment le front
national seraient d'accord avec ça parce
que par exemple l'onu avec ces experts
qui conteste la loi liberticide contre
le contre le terrorisme je ne vois pas
que le front national soit d'accord avec
cinq listes en symbole international le
front national et 8 km et le front
national lui ce qu'il souhaite c'est un
repli identitaire avec une france
éternelle c'est pas notre projet c'est
pas notre projet mais nous disons qu'il
ya aujourd'hui une question de
souveraineté et je prends toujours
l'exemple du ceta qui est un traité de
libre-échange que qui n'est pas soumis
au vote du parlement pour l'instant mais
qui est déjà entrée en vigueur et le par
le parlement français avait rejeté le
ceta mais comme à l'échelle européenne
il est accepté alors la souveraineté
nationale est complètement mise à terre
donc c'est une double mauvaise humeur
voyait entre eux n'a pas été axé affaire
close non mais je veux dire pour moi
c'est pas la mer des maths ait
franchement cette affaire de assez
symbolique
oui